Challenge accepted. We're going to look at a a
function called the sigmoid. Sigmoid meaning s-like, right, sig,
sigma-ish, sigmoid. So we're going to define this, this,
the sigmoid using the letter. Sigma and it's going to
be applied to the activation just like we
were doing before, but instead of thresholding it at
zero, what it's instead going to do is
compute this function of a, one over one plus
e to the, e to the minus a, and what do we
know about this function? Well, it is. Ought to be clear that
as the activation gets less and less and less, we'd want it
to go to zero, and in fact it does, right. So, as
a goes to negative infinity, the negative a goes to infinity. E
to the infinity is something really, really big. So it's one over
1 plus something really big, which is like 1 over something huge,
which is almost zero. So, the sigmoid function goes toward, this function
that we defined here, goes to zero as the activation goes.
To negative infinity, that's great, that's just like threshold, and as
the activation gets really really large, we're talking about e to
the minus something really large, which is like e to the
almost, or like e to the negative infinity which is like
almost zero, so one over one plus zero is essentially one.
So on the one limit, it go towards zero, and the
other limit it goes towards one, and in fact we can
just Draw this so you can see what it really
looks like you know, minus five and below it's essentially at
zero, and then it makes this kind of gradual, you can see
why it's sigmoid s-shaped curve, then it comes back up to
the top and it's basically at one by the time it
get to five. So instead of just an abrupt of transition
to zero, we had this gradual transition between negative five and
five. And this is great because it's differentiable, so. What do
you think Charles, does this answer your question?
>> It does, I buy that.
>> Alright good so if we have units
like this now we can take derivatives which
means we can use this gradient decent idea all over the place. So not only is
this function differentiable but the derivative itself has
a very beautiful form. In particular it turns
out... That if you take the derivative of
this sigma function, it can be written as the
function itself times one minus the function itself. So this is
just, this is just really elegant and simple. So, if you have,
you know, the sigma function in your code, there's nothing special that
you need for the derivative. You could just compute it this way.
So we would, it's not a bad exercise to go through and
do this. Practice your calculus, we just did this together but it's
not that fun to watch. So I would suggest doing it on
your own, and if you have any trouble we'll, we'll provide additional
information for you to, to help you work that out.
>> But when you do it on your own make sure that no one is watching.
>> [LAUGH] Well they can watch, they just
probably won't enjoy it very much. So, so can
we say anything about why this form kind
of makes sense? So, so what's neat about this
is. As we, as our activation gets very,
very negative, then our sigma value gets closer and
closer to zero. And if you look at what
our derivative is there, it's something like zero times
something like one minus zero, whereas the derivative as
you get to very, very large as, that's like
sigma's going to one. And you get 1 times
1 minus 1 minus 1, so essentially 1 times 0.
So you can see the derivatives flatten out for
very large and very negative a's. And when a is
like, zero, so what happens when a is like
zero? Boy, what does happen when a is like zero?
Charles, what happens if we plug zero into this sigma function?
>> You get one half.
>> Is that obvious? Oh, I see, because e to the minus
a, that's zero, so e to the zero is one, one over one
plus one, so a half. And then our derivative at that point
is a half times a half, or a quarter, so that's kind of neat.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So so this is really, this, it's, it's in
a very nice form for being able to work with it.
>> But it's probably worth saying that.
Surely you could use other functions that are
different, and there might be good reasons to do
that. This one just happens to be a very
nice way of dealing with the threshold in question.
>> Yeah and there's other ways that are also nice. So again,
the main properties here are that as activation gets very negative it goes
to zero, as activation gets very positive it goes to one, and
there's this smooth transition in between,
there's other ways of making that shape.